that's dog back there okay about those
little things of cost of promoting some
success was like are you talk about no
can you speak louder
sure hold the mic up
all right I guess I'll just try to speak
louder uh yeah so the chair has Smith
this is gonna be about the cost of
factory no it's going to be about a much
more boring problem I guess but a much
simpler one to explain how to compile it
so I guess my apologies in advance so
the basic plan here is I'm gonna lay
down some context for what the regime
we're working in is or at least the one
that I'm thinking in I know that all the
other talks have seemed very like
theoretical and high-level and this talk
is going to be very much the opposite
where we think about more of the details
of what things turn into and I kind of
want to get into more theorist heads
like what are the costs of the things
that you're talking about and then I'll
start going through some of the building
blocks which is just going to be like a
somewhat poor surface code review and
then I'll talk about how we're gonna put
those building blocks together into this
random circuit sampling problem and then
we'll give some numbers at the end so
context so this layout the reason that
I'm talking about this so first of all
it's important to understand the cost of
fault tolerance in order to know like
when will we be able to do these things
and should we spend more money now to
make them happen sooner or should we
wait and these kinds of prioritization
questions that the companies care about
also it's it's sort of nice to have
these simple well-defined problems that
you can come back to and say oh using
these things over I learned over the
last year this is now cheaper or easier
to do in some way so it's nice to have a
baseline and also it's nice when you can
tell experimentalists here's a thing
where if you have this many cubits and
this much fidelity you could do this and
maybe that's interesting to them so I
come from a team that does
superconducting qubits so most of the
things that I have in my head are
related to superconducting qubits so we
kind of imagine that your qubits are
laid out on a grid and now you have two
Deakin activity two nearest neighbors
that we expect Gate Fidelity's on the
order of 99.9 percent so when you have
an error and by an error I mean a random
poly like a depolarizing error
that should happen about one in a
thousand times when you do the gate and
I'll mention this later but when we're
doing these estimates we're not really
thinking in terms of the physical gate
error we're thinking in terms of at the
logical level what does the physical
gate error mean for us and in particular
what we care about is how much logical
error suppression we get as we increase
the code distance of our constructions
so what we want is five decibels of
suppression per code distance but what
we tell Hardware people is we want 99%
0.9% fidelity in terms of the speed of
the hardware superconducting qubits are
pretty fast they can do gates in tens or
hundreds of nanoseconds and in terms of
the server in terms of the surface code
that kind of cashes out too we want to
be able to measure all the stabilizers
that are present about a million times
per second and also there's the problem
of the system you wrap around your
quantum computer in order to control it
and keep things going and that system
will have some speed that it's able to
do a measurement and react to it to pick
another measurement to do and that's
also an important speed when for these
systems and we kind of assume that
that's gonna be around a 10 micro second
round-trip time so we can do about a
hundred thousand sequential things at
the logic level so another caveat is the
the numbers that I'm giving are not
fixed in stone in any sense like these
numbers keep changing they have been
getting better over time so don't get
too depressed when I show this next
slide so currently fault tolerance is
very very expensive and you can tell
because of the number of zeros on this
slide so on the right there's a
classical an gate which is a couple
transistors arranged into a circuit a
particular way and that'll do and you
know 10 billion times a second for as
long as you want and on in on the right
this is like a magic state factory
you'll really have to understand what
that is the point is that it's it's kind
of big and when you work out how many
qubits are using for how much time you
end up with numbers that have like 10
cubed seconds
if you ever hear people say things like
Grover speedups are not enough this is
why they're saying that is because you
need to overcome this starting penalty
of ten billion or a trillion depending
on how you run the numbers before your
algorithm really starts coming out ahead
which is why you really you really want
an exponential speed-up at least given
given these sorts of numbers in order to
overcome that penalty so as I mentioned
the cheapest thing that we know how to
do that's hard to do classically but
easy to do quantumly
is to just generate a random circuit and
run it because that's the thing that the
quantity are natively does and the kind
of unpredictability of the gates or the
fact that there's no structure to them
makes it very difficult for classical
computers to simulate them and of course
the downside is that it's not really a
useful problem like maybe you can use to
make certified random number generators
out of them and also it's not easy to
check that it's working but well here we
are let's move on to describing the the
surface code and the first thing I'm
going to do is just stay on this slide
for a couple minutes and talk about all
the pieces of a little surface code
patch so when we talk about the surface
code we're talking about like this this
checkerboard pattern of parity checks so
each of the black squares here is a four
body
operator that we're going to measure as
often as we can and each of the the
white squares is also a four body
operator but in another basis so one of
them is you know zzzz and the other is
X's and the idea is that if you have an
error happened somewhere on the chip
like say here that error is going to be
X or Z or x times Z or will decompose
into something some some of them and so
it'll cause these stabilizers that are
next to it to flip and that allow you to
identify than error happened and reverse
it and in order for an error to actually
be undetected you need a whole chain of
them which goes from one side all the
way to the other like you get
an ex flip and then another ex flip and
then another ex flip and another ex flip
and then other ex flip and then you
don't see anything wrong but your cubit
was damaged I've also highlighted the
kind of logical observables so these are
where we're storing the information so
any any qubit is just an ant commuting
pair of observables and here is the anti
commuting pair of observables in red and
in blue there's also these kind of
boundaries where you do these two body
measurements which is good because you
don't want to have to go off to infinity
in real life and also it's very hard to
make chips on a torus so it's it's nice
that they stop and that we know how to
stop them so I don't know if people can
see this very well but I have shown
these little yellow circles for where
the data qubits are I haven't shown any
for the measurement qubits but
essentially you can think there's like
another grid offset by a little bit
where the measurement qubits are living
and you can tell us distance five
because if you count the dots it's one
two three four five from one side to the
other now unfortunately a distance five
qubit like this is not good enough to do
much computation with it's like
experimentally interesting perhaps and
you could demonstrate a lot of things
with such a qubit but if you want to do
computations with it that are
classically difficult you need something
bigger and in particular I think you
need something around distance 13 so
that's around 400 physical qubits and
when you take this we have this way of
approximating what we expect the air the
logical error rate to be per cycle based
on simulations that Austin Fowler has
done and based on those you sort of
expect this 5 DB of suppression per code
distance with an initial offset of 3 and
you just plug in that equation and then
you switch from decibels to probability
and you get like a 10 to the minus 8
chance of failure of this qubit per
cycle and you've given that I said we're
gonna have these cycles at about a
megahertz
that gives you a half-life of about a
minute or two so this will last about a
minute
before you kind of start expecting that
there's been an error and the qubits no
good anymore
now if you want to computation you of
course need many cubits and if you want
to do a classically intractable
computation you need more than 50
because people can store that much in
disk so we're gonna need 60 of em or me
yeah 60 of them and so this whole system
now has a smaller half-life because each
of the individual qubits could fail and
their 60 of them and their half-life's
are a minute so perhaps not surprisingly
the system half-life is around a second
you know sixtieth of a minute and now
our total physical qubit count is
getting more to around 2500 so this is
how we're gonna store the information is
this is the layout and now how are we
gonna operate on it so there there's a
style of performing operations in the
surface code called live surgery and
basically what I'm showing here is a
lattice surgery where you have an
initial configuration where you have two
qubits that are separate and then you
measure out the cube the data qubits in
between them to prepare them into a
known state and then you kind of just
turn on the stabilisers connecting the
two qubits and what this allows you to
do is it allows you to determine the
like the X X parity between those two
qubits or there's easy parity depending
on which sides you joined the way that
you can tell that that's happening I've
highlighted in red here like these kind
of diamonds
each of these diamonds corresponds to
one of these stabilizers and if you
multiply together every single one of
them you're left with you know these
three qubits and x times these three
qubits and X which is exactly the
observable that I claimed we were
measuring so you you are in fact
measuring the the parity and it's right
there it can become quite inconvenient
to have to show all of these diagrams in
terms of these time slices and so we
often use this 3d notation where we only
show where the boundaries are of the
qubits over time so here like this the
square or this cube this pipe
corresponds to this thing here just
going through time towards the right and
then when they're joined together well
there's a crossbar here joining them
together and then afterwards they're
going to split back apart although
that's not shown in the
slices here so there's gonna be more of
these types of diagrams and I know it's
it's unfortunately difficult to get used
to reading them in the span of a
30-minute talk but it's also difficult
to get used to reading the kind of
configurations the time slices so I
don't actually know how to explain the
surface code really well in 30 minutes
unfortunately so that was the sort of
two qubit measurements we also have
single qubit operations so an important
one that maybe doesn't seem like an
operation is just reorienting the qubit
so if the wrong side is facing outwards
and you want to fix it so the other side
is facing outward how do you do the
three-point turn to get the qubit in to
the right orientation so we used to do
this with more space but then Daniel at
insky found this way to do it with just
a two by one section you can kind of
maybe follow how the boundaries are
moving around here or you can look at
this and you should picture in your head
like a barber pole where the colors are
just going around gradually except it's
been kind of discretized and in order to
avoid having any two of the boundaries
get too close to each other because our
error our chance of error is ultimately
determined by how close does you know
this black boundary on the face here get
close to the black boundary on the other
face there and so there's a lot of
restrictions and how you can move things
around in particular the thing that I
like about this one is it has this
little little notch which I would not
have come up with and I think it's great
once you have the patch rotation that's
the majority of the Hadamard operation
so what I'm indicating here this little
yellow strip is that you apply a demur
to every single one of the data qubits
and what this effectively does is it
people call it the transversal Hadamard
as if it does a high tomorrow to the
logical qubit but it gives you a logical
qubit oriented the wrong way and then
you fix it with this Pat rotation would
you actually spend all of the time doing
but ultimately the point is you can do a
Hadamard and you can fit it into a two
by one footprint there's also a
construction to do the S skate in a two
by one footprint which is more
complicated you don't have to understand
the details of this slide this this is
actually still not published
this is something I figured out last
week but the point is you can do the
escape and this is something that I'm
quite happy about because they used to
be much more awkward so those are like
the basic single qubit operations and in
combination with the ability to do that
parody measurement you can actually do
the entire Clifford set that's that's
maybe not so obvious like that was one
of the things that was surprising about
a lot of surgery initially is that you
could get the see not gate out of these
parity measurements but you can and so C
naught and H and s together are
universal for clifford of course we
don't want to do just a clipper
computation because that would be
classically tractable there those
circuits are easy to simulate so we need
some other gate in this case it's a t
gate but I'm not going to be applying t
gates to individual qubits I'm going to
be implying them to paly product
observables like you know X on the first
qubit times Z on the second qubit times
Y on the fifth cubed or something like
that so when you see this like big box
with a little T next to it you could
imagine in your minds you know preparing
each of the qubits into the correct
observable and then putting the parity
all into one accumulator qubit and
applying a T there and then getting it
off in practice that's not the way that
we're going to do it we're going to
implement it we have an efficient way of
doing this but if you're conceptually
confused about what this means to phase
a multi qubit observable this this is
what you can have in your head we're
going to phase the minus one eigenstate
by 45 degrees we're going to leave the
plus one I can state alone and the
reason that we kind of care about this
generalized thing is in lattice surgery
the difference between oh I'm going to
apply apply T gate to one qubit that
apply to many qubits is like adding on
more of these connecting elements
between your T State coming in and your
data qubits going up through time and
this this is an extremely small
difference I'm actually exaggerating the
spacing here just so that you can see it
in practice these the separation is not
of order to code distance which is what
it looks like here it's of order 1
I mean is literally one so we need to be
able to do these t gates but they're not
native to the surface code and the way
that it's done is you perform magic
state distillation where which is a
process that takes in multiple noisy
versions of a state and outputs a
smaller number of more reliable ones in
every once in a while you you know fail
some sort of check and you throw away
two state so here is a circuit which
performs magic state distillation this
is also from Daniel attend ski and as
you can see it kind of has this property
over just applying t gates to various
poly product observables and so this is
going to fit pretty nicely into lattice
surgery which is this next slide so
again this is it's not incredibly
important that you understand all the
details of how this works I just want to
have in your head that there is this
there is this structure and we are
performing the distillation there are a
bunch of tricks in in this to make it a
little better so in particular you might
notice that the sizes of the pipes are
not symmetrical here they're like some
of them are like squeezed the reason for
that is there are some errors that are
detected by the distillation process
even if they if they occur in these
pipes and if they're detected we're
willing to tolerate them happening more
often and so we moved the boundaries
closer together
another trick that's happening is
normally every time you inject a tea
gate you you either perform a tea or an
inverse tea and if you perform an
inverse tea you have to fix it by doing
an s gate because you went the wrong way
by 45 degrees you're off by 90 degrees
you have to fix it but it turns out that
sometimes there are ways of simplifying
which escapes you do if you build up a
bunch of them over time so normally you
would have to do an S key for every
single one of these but it turns out
that this particular system has some
nice properties that guarantees you need
at most five of them and so I'm using
that to reduce the depth of this
structure without that trick it would be
much deeper so there's these kinds of
like algebraic properties going on
behind the scenes here too to make the
depth lower
so to review the building blocks that
I've established we have this 5 by 12
board of distance 13 cubits covering
about 2,500 physical elements we have
our single qubit gates we have our
generalized tea gate and we have our
distillation procedure and now we're
going to put that all together into an
algorithm so the basic idea is we're
going to cut out some of this space and
use it as a working area and we're only
going to be operating at any given time
on the qubits that are adjacent to the
working area but we're able to move it
and the way you move the working areas
you actually move the qubits to the
right of it to the left or vice versa so
there's enough space because all of our
single qubit operations are two by one
for us to do a Hadamard gate or an S
gate every single one of those qubits in
the active area in parallel in like
depth 3 because that's how deep the
Hadamard gate is also this is enough
space to fit the teeth the T State
distillation and also it's enough space
to fit that like generalize poly product
T and to connect it to some subset of
the qubits so basically what we're going
to do is we're just going to sweep the
thing back and forth picking random poly
product observables to phase you know
being careful to make sure that the anti
commute with the one before to prevent
it for being too easy and do that for as
long as we can but you know we have a
second of time to work with and it turns
out that you need to back at the
envelope calculations and that it seems
like it's enough so here I'm just adding
together all the things that I talked
about in some that I didn't to say how
quickly do we do this cycle of moving
and doing the generalized T and so forth
and it happens about 4,000 times a
second based on other
back-of-the-envelope calculations that
I'm not going to show it seems like if
you do a thousand of them you get enough
mixing so that's classically intractable
like probably way more than enough and
you're still getting only
like only like a 90% chance of air which
maybe sounds bad to theoretician but if
you talk to hardware engineers for a
system that big running that long that
sounds amazing like the the supremacy
paper I don't know if anyone here like
read the details but the fidelity at the
end of that of the circuit that they ran
was 0.1% so they had to run a lot of
repetitions to see that signal out of
the noise so that like 10% sounds
completely amazing also in the the like
misc supremacy experiment it was like
depth 20 and given the the ordering of
how the gates work you could maybe get a
signal from one side of the chip and
back in that amount of depth but there
wasn't a lot of time for round trips of
information there's just enough time to
get things mixed once we're here it's
going back and forth about a hundred
times so like it seems like there's a
lot more buffer so I think I might have
gone too fast but no it's not that bad
also it's the last it's the last talk so
no one would care if they got to leave
early in summary it looks like you would
need 25,000 qubits to do this it might
be possible to get a little lower and if
we're doing a thousand operations and it
takes about 0.25 seconds to get a sample
and you get about 10% fidelity so I'm
just going to talk for a minute about
why would you possibly do this given
that it's already been done in this like
this this thing random circuit sampling
is so great at having a quantum
advantage that you don't need the fault
tolerance but the thing is if you want
to really make the argument that the
extended church-turing thesis is false
you need a system that you can scale up
and so the asymptotic sacktual e apply
to it
if you took the current NIST system and
you you tried to scale it up you need to
wait for the hardware engineers to
improve the error for each of the scale
ups you did and so there's like a
certain important practical sense in
which you can't make asymptotic claims
until you have the ability to to easily
scale also like just
the numbers are a lot better so that
like that it would be much more
compelling in a sense but I mean people
here probably have opinions about that
so maybe I'll open it up to questions
now
[Applause]
this end up fitting on one chip or where
this means like a lot of information
being transmitted into a chip that's
kind of a complicated question because
there's different levels of it could be
on a different chip like you could
imagine chips being in different fridges
or just be next to each other and
connected in different ways I I don't
know what the the current plans are in
terms of what size of chip it would be I
imagine you would not want to try to
fabricate a device that had that many
elements on it that were quantum in
nature and have it expect it to work
well universally across it so I guess
maybe the answers I'd expected use
multiple chips out at one point
performing gates in parallel within the
sliding window yep that was I was just
wondering it like the the way that
hardware is set up is it is it natural
to perform gates in parallel I guess for
super yapper superconducting qubits it's
very natural to do the gates in parallel
like there's a separate wire going to
every qubit with its own microwave
signal it's not like ion traps where
there's this kind of shared laser that
where they could be interfering with
each other and the reason for limiting
the windows just because there are only
so many wires or something no no act
actually every single one of these when
I say they're idle I don't mean that
they're not doing anything they're
actually very very actively constantly
measuring these stabilizers in order to
prevent errors from accumulating I just
mean they're idle from like the logical
algorithm makes sense and the reason
that I did that was purely to avoid
having to have even more space if I
wanted them all to be active I would
need a space next to every one of them
and it would essentially double the cost
but but in principle at double the cost
you could perform a gate unlike oh like
a bunch of disjoint pairs of qubits
the entire yeah yeah if you put like
access hallways here and there and there
and also a connecting one along the
bottom then yeah you can do the parallel
operation across every single qubit in
the system that's actually one of the
like architectures recommended in Daniel
lutein skis paper where he doesn't ever
bother doing any Clifford operation to
the qubits he he just keeps applying T
gates and targeting the correct poly
products
would that change considerably if you
change if the connectivity was different
like if your cubes were more connected
or let alone fully connected or it's
really complicated because you might
even switch your error correcting code
under that situation certainly if you
had two layers and they could crosstalk
the surface code has a transversal C
naught which is much cheaper so yeah it
would probably change the cost but it's
difficult to say how with those
specifics and even with specifics it's a
lot of work
yes this is pressing your native
question but I always want to ask why is
the surface called the best option
there's many Quan quotes it's it's
because it has a good threshold and
because it has this planar structure
that's kind of what it comes down to
as the technology tool for all these
types has been that's still a console
problem no one has an idea how to solve
when you say steps could you be
twenty-five thousand cubits yeah no
there are a bunch of technical
challenges that prevent us from simply
building it immediately for example the
the cryo stat like the fridge that we
put it in to keep it cold only has so
much cooling power and if you tried to
fit this make qubits in and all of your
wires you would overwhelm it so you need
to make a bigger fridge also the wires
are heavy and like the support structure
around it would collapse so you have to
fix that like a ton of individual
technical problems that must be solved
the theory side I feel like we're kind
of ahead of the hardware I'm there's a
lot of software that has to work so
there's a lot of programmer work that
also has to be done but I feel like the
theory side is pretty robust in
particular people have thought of things
that you might not have thought they'd
worry about like what if there's a qubit
broken in the middle of one of the
patches how do you deal with that and we
have a nice way of dealing with that or
the physical hardware is not technically
qubits they're harmonic oscillators they
have you know zero state of one state
and then a two state in a three state
and all the way up to wherever that
breaks down and we have a way where we
worry about what if they leak out how do
we get them back in like when I show
they stabilize our configurations and I
show them staying in place that's not
quite right what we intend to do is to
have everything that constantly
jittering back and forth so that qubits
spent about an equal amount of time as
data and measurement because you can
reset your measurement qubits and that
gets them out of the Tuesday
yeah there is a desperate to see results
out for checking effort
yeah we we definitely want to do that
but we we want to do it like processing
the information online instead of
offline so it it's just a lot of work
yeah
I mean hardware is only recently gotten
to the point where it would be viable
like you need to you need your air rate
to be below the threshold in order to
see an improvement as you go from
distance three to distance five and so
in that sense it's only recently that it
could have been done even in principle
and other than that it experiments are
just harder than you think beauty beyond
our imaginations worth of being
difficult it's not it's not always even
like big fundamental obstacles it's like
oh the power went out today and the
fridge is warmed up better it we better
have power back up in the next building
like there's a million little things
that can all go wrong and you need to
get all the pieces working very well and
consistently well in order to see stuff
like this
so some doesn't mean it's mostly
engineering problems for the distance
five experiment yes I would say it's
mostly an engineering problem there's no
theoretical obstacles or unknown
hardware things it's it's a matter of a
lot of people doing a lot of work to to
make things work well all the time you
were mentioning that it is challenging
mm I would say no but I'm speaking
beyond my knowledge at that point I I
will say I don't think we have the same
problem classical machines have where
they're trying to go as like as
absolutely fast as possible like we
where the speed that we run is kind of
determined by the physics in a way
that's I guess the classical speed is
also determined by physics but I've
never heard someone say let's run the
qubits faster oh no it'll get hotter I
don't think it works that way it's more
like the qubits wouldn't work as well
that they worry about
yes the numbers you gave in the last
slide they are all relative to the sixty
cubits that you mentioned earlier yeah
okay and if I want more than 60 how much
listed oh well I mean if you want a
hundred I guess you could multiply this
by a hundred divided by sixty but you
probably need to make the co distance go
up a little bit because you have a
bigger system in order to prevent it
from decaying quickly so that that will
add this every time you want to make the
system ten times bigger in in space-time
you probably want to increase the code
distance by two and given that the
current code distance was thirteen you
would go up to code distance 15 so you'd
multiply by 100 over 60 times 15 over
that would tell me
like let's say you had this thing
backwards would you run good night
vision what's the escape I mean when
it's that size this is basically the
only classically intractable thing you
can do but there's all kinds of fun
experiments you can do to test that it's
working like you just run Clifford's
circuits all day long and you can check
very well that they are doing the
correct thing just validating every one
of these constructions like that that
the single qubit gates work and at the
distillation works and just all kinds of
validation experiments is what I expect
people to run other than that because at
this size you can't really do anything
else classically intractable I guess I'm
sort of the type of person to be like
well then you should use a classical
computer instead they're they're
simulators that will yeah right they're
gonna make a quantum computer or we're
going to figure out quantum mechanics is
wrong all right I heard those is a good
outcome for us
[Applause]